Speaker 1: All right. So Donald Trump held
two rallies over the weekend. We are really
getting into just the very, very end here of the
2022 midterm campaign period. We have debates
this week, next week, the week after, I'll be
livestreaming a bunch of them. Donald Trump's
rally schedule has gotten very busy and each
of these rallies wilder and crazier than the
previous. Let's go in reverse chronological order.
Donald Trump speaking Sunday night or afternoon,
as it were, in Arizona in support of Carrie Lake
and Blake Masters and other really dangerous,
extreme candidates. Donald Trump was
completely, completely, completely incoherent,
talking about the planting of documents,
jumping back and forth between they were
my documents and I had the right to have them
at Mar a Lago to they planted the documents.
Listen to this. Making no sense. Soaking wet.
Trump dripping wet. As he tells these lies.
Speaker 3: The National Archives put a trigger
warning on the Constitution of the United States.
Did you know that? And the Bill of Rights and
other great documents that we have in our country,
founding documents trigger considering them to
be dangerous. They consider the Constitution
to be dangerous. These are radical left lunatics.
And they lose documents. They plant documents. Oh,
let's see. Is there a book on nuclear destruction
or the building of a nuclear weapon? Shipley
Let's put that back. So let's put that book in
with Trump. Now, they plant documents. I mean,
they have a terrible reputation.
Speaker 1: So Trump now saying,
despite at the very same rally saying, listen,
these were my documents. They took them,
they got to give them back. They're
my documents. Now he's saying, well,
they planted stuff and it included
a book on how to make a nuke.
Wow. That's a new allegation. I hadn't heard that
before. Trump then says, Listen, everything they
found was mine. They should give it all back
away. But I thought you said they planted the
stuff. Was it yours or was it not yours?
Speaker 3: They don't get enough credit.
By contrast, I had a small number of boxes in
storage at Mar a Lago, guarded by Secret Service
and my people and everybody. I mean, it's safe
when you look at these other people, what they
did and the FBI raided my home and violated my
Fourth Amendment rights and many other rights. And
under the Sox decision, this is a very important
decision that was made the court the Sox decision,
because, again, it had to do with Bill Clinton
and his socks. There is no crime. You know,
there is no crime. It's not a crime. And they
should give me immediately back everything
that they've taken from me because it's.
Speaker 1: Mine, right? Oh, but I thought
you said they planted it. So now he says it's
his stuff. Give it back. Fine. But for a while,
like 5 minutes earlier, the story was the stuff
was planted. Another completely unbelievable
moment. Arizona gubernatorial Republican candidate
Carrie Lake talks about Hunter Biden's crack pipe,
really elevating the discourse at these rallies.
Speaker 2: Now, I got to tell you, you know, I
have some of these know nothing consultants
who tell me, you know, you really need to
back away from President Trump right now. And
I say to them, put down Hunter's crack pipe
right now. Woof. Wouldn't it be horrible?
Wouldn't it be horrible? What would it say
about my character if I stepped away from
my friends? If I step away from my friends,
that means I would step away from you. And I
will never step away from the people of Arizona.
And so for those know nothing consultants and
the media, I want to show you what it looks
like when I step away from President Trump.
Speaker 1: Show us and gives Trump a big hug
there. So really just out of control with the
Hunter Biden stuff. And then she and by the way,
she could win. She's leading by like a point
or two right now. That woman could be the next
governor of Arizona, as scary and horrifying
as that is. And then Donald Trump now also the
anti-trans and parents rights portion of these
speeches. It's a staple at every rally now.
Speaker 3: One of the first things we must do is
stand up for parents rights. Can you believe I'm
even saying that we're going to fight for parents
rights? Who would ever think you have to say that
we're going to fight for parents rights? Can
ten years ago, have you said that to say you're
crazy? What? Of course you're going to fight for
parents rights today. You have to make a case for
we will get critical race theory out of our
schools, out of our military, which we had
it out and out of every part of our federal,
state and local governments. And at long last,
every parent in America must be empowered to opt
out of the forced indoctrination in the classroom
and send their child to the public, private
charter, religious or home school of their choice.
Speaker 1: Then he goes on to say, No teacher
should be allowed to teach transgender,
whatever that means, without parental
permission. So that is now a staple of
the rallies. That's the Arizona rally. Trump
dripping wet, confused, extreme. But that was
nothing compared to the previous day's rally in
Nevada, which is where we're going to go next